we i i started going down this rabbit
hole of thinking about what is money
when i realized that i was in essence
going to lose my company
right and destroy the livelihoods of all
my employees and you know waste 30 years
of my life and so when i started
thinking about it and you know it's
helpful when jerome powell says we're
not even thinking about thinking about
raising interest rates you know your
strategy of investing in bonds is broken
when i started thinking about it what i
realized is
money is energy
money is economic energy social
political energy currency is a medium
through which the energy moves
um
if if you wish to um if you wish to hold
energy and transport energy you need a
technology
we're not using gold anymore when we use
gold as i pointed out it's expensive and
it's uh and it's cumbersome
currencies don't work
the us dollar is the the strongest
currency in the world but is losing 15
to 20 percent of its value a year
the peso is losing 40 to 50 percent of
its value a year the boulevard is losing
100 percent 95 98 of its value a year
so once you start thinking about it that
way you start thinking
well
what's a better way to store economic
energy through time and you realize that
the currencies don't work
gold doesn't work
so
what is money well money money in the
last 30 years became the s p index you
buy a diversified portfolio of companies
of stocks
which is a little bit better
because maybe you're getting bled two
percent a year by the management team
but the company's making money and so
maybe you can hold value
it turns out that the money is losing
about 10 of its value year and the s p
index is going up about 10 a year and
you look at that for 100 years and
there's a very interesting correlation
there
a diversified portfolio of assets
is tracking the money supply
okay interesting
what's the problem with that
well the problem with holding stocks as
a store of value is if the stock goes up
by a factor of 10
there's a management team that has a
fiduciary obligation to issue more stock
there's a temptation to issue stock
stocks aren't scarce the the amount of
equity shares will also go up if the
stock is overvalued versus the
fundamentals of the company
the ceo is almost certainly going to
issue more stock and so
that's one problem the second problem is
stocks have political nexus they have
management teams they're in countries
they can be unionized
i can put a tariff on the product i've
got a competitor what if the ceo goes
bonkers
all sorts of interesting problems what
if the company gets expropriated by the
government you know or the jurisdiction
it operates within
so
stocks are an imperfect approach
better than gold
the other approach is by a bunch of
buildings in new york city by scarce
desirable real estate in miami los
angeles london
that's a an interesting idea and the
best idea in the 20th century if you're
gonna if you're going to try to either
create
wealth or hold your wealth if you want
to hold your wealth
you buy a billion dollars worth of
property
if you want to create wealth you borrow
a billion dollars
and you buy a billion dollars of
property
and you start with a million dollars of
equity a sliver of equity and what
you're doing is you're going short the
currency and you're going along the
property so if i told you
let's go to argentina
if i told you in argentina the peso is
going to go from 1 peso to the dollar
to 5 pesos to the dollar to 10 pesos to
the dollar to 20 pesos to the dollar to
40 to 80 to 100
the black market rate right now is 210
pesos to the dollar
220. if i told you it was going to
collapse
from 1 to 220
and you had 20 years of notice
what's your best strategy
take your million pesos convert to
dollars and you're gonna have 220
million pesos in 20 years you're going
to look rich
better strategy is borrow a million
pesos convert to dollars
wow best strategy would be mortgage your
entire company in pesos sell equity in
your company in pesos convert it all to
dollars
and then get the dollars out of the
country
because if they're in the country if
you're if the million
pesos is converted to dollars in a bank
in argentina then the government will
basically pass a law force your dollars
to be converted back into pesos devalued
them
and i happened to have some experience
with that because i actually had a
million dollars in argentina during the
last currency collapse they converted to
pesos they devalued it ten to one
a day later i'd lost 90 percent of my
money
so
simple idea
short the currency which is collapsing
go long property and then get the
property out of the country
because the property in the country
is also going to devalue
because the property's value based upon
the extreme of cash flows right
if the building is uh has got a a rentor
and it's got a lease and the lease is
capped at cpi or or or denominated in
local currency when the currency
collapses the value of of the rental
income also collapses so
wouldn't it be great if i could buy a a
virtual building
in argentina
using borrowed pesos
and then what if i could spirit the
building out of the country and rent it
to people in london or new york city
that's what bitcoin is
bitcoin is digital property
that you can teleport
anywhere in space instantly
and it's also perfected property with
with the lowest maintenance cost
you know you don't have the property tax
you have on a building you don't have to
repaint the thing every 10 years you
don't have to worry about leaks in the
roof
so if i could buy a big if i could buy a
billion dollars worth of property
and it was in cyberspace
and if you couldn't make any more of it
if i capped it at 21 million
city blocks in cyberspace
and if i could hold it for a thousand
years
i might have a better idea than buying a
city block in manhattan
or a building in london
or even a company
and it's a lot better idea than buying
30 000 pounds worth of gold
why
because real estate developer is going
to create more buildings gold miner is
going to create more gold mayors are
going to pass a property tax and they're
going to
they're going to put some kind of
enjoinder or some kind of restriction on
your rents
rent control you're building
something you know acts of god are going
to create earthquakes and floods
and lightning strikes
and none of that stuff's happening in
cyberspace
so the whole idea of bitcoin is
it's perfected engineered gold crypto
gold
with none of the none of the defects of
gold you can't mine any more of it it's
it's weightless i can move it at the
speed of light it never decomposes
i can deco i can i can break it into a
thousand pieces in a second
send it to a thousand places and
recompose it
uh all using a computer program
and i can take personal custody of it
maybe the most the most powerful two
ideas are
i can hold possession of a billion
dollars of bitcoin in my head
just holding a password or a set of
private keys that's a pretty big idea
maybe the first the first time in the
history of the human race that you can
actually take possession of your wealth
and take it to the grave with you or
take it anywhere else on earth with you
and even if i
put a gun to your head the most i can do
is kill you
i can't take it
and this is a very interesting idea
every other form of property in the
history of the human race
i pull the gun i get it all
right my incentive is to violence with
bitcoin i pull the trigger i get none of
it
so
the incentive is the negotiation i'd
rather have half
then zero right and it's a very
interesting idea big idea
and the second big idea is got super
intimidated by the way
i'm
yeah i
the second big idea is it's a monitor
it's a virus
it's it's a cyber virus it's a it's a
chain reaction in cyberspace or it's a
life form in cyberspace
bitcoin is a bank in cyberspace run by
incorruptible software
and the software
the software itself is gonna basically
protect your money
the problem with software is i don't
trust the computer it's on
if it's on a if it's on a single phone i
can seize the phone and reprogram the
software so if i came up with a bank and
a bank that was run by software how do i
prevent any human being from corrupting
it
the thing that makes it incorruptible is
i release thousands tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of identical
copies in cyberspace and it's
self-replicating
and all of the copies keep track of each
other and when one of them is corrupted
it gets kicked off the network
so you could think of it is i released a
life form plankton
or a virus
and i let go
or a swarm
now you're a part of the swarm i shoot
you it doesn't help you have the genetic
code i shoot you just now i obliterate
all of you know the the algae in the
atlantic won't stop it
i eliminate all of the bacteria in your
body won't stop it right it's a virus
it's going to keep spreading
and the beauty of the system is
it's in essence this chain reaction in
cyberspace and the only purpose of the
chain reaction is to protect the
integrity of the network
there will never be more than 21 million
bitcoin
so
what you've got
is
is truth
and integrity
released
as a as a cyber virus and you can if you
choose to join that network
you avail yourself of all of the
benefits of that network how many of the
21 million bitcoin have been i've been
mined already
about 18 and a half million so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you